very nice to see you this morning and
indoors
for a change i'm sarah let's come to you
first
tell us how you ended up in a caravan
on the driveway there would be plenty of
people who lodge you for it but
you know we've got some questions about
it
yeah basically um i leave it out with my
mom who was 84 year old
and i was working at one local hospital
and i was working in the current 19 ward
and i knew that to keep my mom safe
though i couldn't leave him in the house
any longer
so we decided that we had to move out
and unfortunately it was so quick that
we
couldn't get a flat obviously getting
contracts and stuff we had no furniture
so we went to our local um caravan sales
yard and we bought
a caravan for 600 pounds and i told them
we need to deliver as soon as possible
because obviously we i need to move out
like isip really
so they delivered it to us on the monday
um at one o'clock
as the country went into lockdown at
five o'clock so myself and gary went
upstairs and got stuff out of our
bedroom that we knew that we were going
to need
um in there and we moved our mattress in
there and then
it was all from there really we just
moved in there and we stayed there for
the whole nine months
gary did you did you ever think that you
were going to be spending you know
the best part of three quarters of a
year camped on the driveway outside the
house
not at all uh we thought maybe max 12
weeks
uh but the days came and went the weeks
came in the months the seasons changed
and uh
we just we were still there so it was
uh it was just totally uh unbelievable
i mean it's all about max and paddy's
road to nowhere the two of you
in the caravan on the driveway plenty of
laughs i'm sure but practically from day
to day
how was it actually living and living
living in a
in a box compared to the house that you
had and did you manage to see your
mother
yeah it was it was really really tough i
mean we know we never slept in a proper
bed or
we never sat in a city at all for nine
months we basically sat in a dick chair
which was put in the doorway of the
caravan uh one of us was blind the bed
and we were swapping like at night to
watch tv uh in the winter it was
freezing cold
in the summer it was absolutely
ridiculously hot
and also the caverns of driving on a
slope so
we'd wake up in the morning our feet up
against a tv screen and stuff it was
like really really tough
and obviously my workload was not really
stressful as well so
it was really really hard um gary
yeah and i say this knowing that my
mother might be watching right now
did the thought never cross your mind
given that it is the the mother-in-law
that perhaps you'd put her out in the
caravan and you two could stay inside
certainly that would be
that would be my first choice with my
mum
the thought did cross my mind for an
hour
not for very long clearly not for very
long
yeah silence that's probably the best
oh no no no mom it would definitely not
be very very long
um but let's focus for a little bit on
the on the reason that you were
you were outside your house for so long
working on the front line of the nhs
uh with an older with an older relative
how how have
has the past you know nine months 12
months been for you
heading off to work and working in such
conditions
it's been really really tough i woke up
in the morning in the coat but i didn't
really sleep to be honest but i know i
got going shifts the next day
and i'd wake up in the morning my heart
used to like literally pill and i think
what am i going to be going into today
it was like so tough it was just
ridiculous
but i knew i had to do it for mom and i
would do it all over again if i had to
to say over
so how then for both of you does it feel
to be off the driveway
back indoors and also we shouldn't
forget having that that close
contact with with your relatives that
i'm sure you've been absolutely crying
out for i haven't seen
my mom and dad for six months longer
than that now and i'm telling you i'm
getting pretty desperate myself
yeah i was i was really really desperate
i missed my sandwich we used like
something that she used to stand in the
porch right
and we used to like sell hearts to her
and a lot of kisses through the door and
speak to her on the phone all the time
but to actually be back in the house
with that is absolutely magical
and we spent christmas day with her
which every day in the pandemic like
while i was in the caravan
i used to wake up when he's thinking if
i've got to spend christmas day in here
i just couldn't have counted them and it
was just unbelievably lucky that we
managed to spend christmas day together
so it was just so hard i mean
i missed it so much well i'm very glad
that you got to spend christmas day
together
very glad that you're back inside very
good glad gary you didn't answer that
question just a couple of minutes ago
otherwise you might be back out in that
caravan
guys been lovely to chat to you this
morning and sarah well done and thanks
for everything you're doing on the front
line we'll speak again
can i say one thing please go on that i
just want to say off to the side
this is this virus is really real it's
definitely not a house and i would just
like everybody please
to go to follow the rules definitely and
stay safe
and obviously guys
listen to these two they've got a very
good point gary sarah
great to have you on the programme this
morning and thanks for being with us
thank you very much
very much thank you so much everybody